you know we have products especially
flown in from Japan you know Paula
japanese restaurant we have a special
products come from the states from all
over the world the most important thing
for artists that we are using on my
quality products it's important that we
are not using too much product like
garlic or things like this yeah and
there's a customer and now at the
momentum like especially very light
slice products I think it's very
important that then you send the whole
world yeah for example and we are using
a little have adduced sis are a kind of
a red paprika it tastes virus word
sweeten it some also a little bit
expensive we've got a Japanese chef
appeal from a china chef we have an
Indian chef so in this kind of formula
you basically cover yourself
because you know we are preparing up to
10,000 digital steering but we have to
plan a long long time before you
actually have the product on hand we
usually start preparing for that in
august/september some Indian spices we
had to fly in from Zurich it was also in
a very short notice basically the
customer came in we didn't know that
they are planning to stay with us and it
was before the world economy long but
then of course then you have to be able
to reacted very quickly